dude see investors think of this
do you know how many i was just in this
podcast 30s of a third time they go on
like conspiracy theories and stuff like
that do you know how many missing
children every year
just go missing a lot but
have you ever
yeah a lot of it is a parent who take
their kids so a lot of that stat if you
look at those statistics a lot of it is
a family member usually a parent that
absconds with their own child so not the
majority of it though a lot of all these
kids never no actually the majority of
it is but you're right that there are a
lot of children that do disappear
and so eight
eight million every year every year
million so let's just say
10 of that
let's say 10 are murdered
even years yeah how nuts is that yeah
although i will say that
it's crazy child sex trafficking
yes but so here's the other thing about
that stat
um child uh pornography one uh the
horrible thing is it's usually done by a
family member or parents
and so
yeah
that's how awful that is jesus and and
and child pornography is a massive
massive problem and market on the black
uh thing but but your child being
abducted by a stranger is actually very
very low it happens of course and it's
horrible but for the most part a lot of
the stuff is i got another factor you
guys yeah you know one out of every 10
murders goes unsolved unsalted yeah
in mexico
oh i've said i thought it would be
higher nine out of ten people get away
with it oh that's how yeah i'm gonna say
yeah my bad nine out of ten get away
with murder in mexico that just
surprised me
isn't that nuts it's hard
million kids missing every year
have you ever seen how many i don't know
why i know all this stuff do you know
how many people go missing in national
forests in america every year so
eighty-one percent dude it's 12 years
old because i was going to yellowstone i
looked it up dude it's this goat they go
into the forest like groups of people
are individuals individuals they're gone
they get like disoriented dude we don't
know
there's theories around it and that's
what the podcast is i'm just gone dude
[ __ ] insane nuts
[ __ ] going to the forest floor some
people think it's about mine some people
think it's other things they think maybe
there's a national park serial killer
they don't know
i like that theory to do type in how
many people go missing in national
[ __ ] parks every year what podcast is
this
theories of a third kind
it's three people it's great though kind
of kind of interesting oh it's fun
because one guy you don't you won't ever
give away his identity he was in a cult
growing up and escaped oh damn
in the united states nuts dude
nuts bro
so this is a missing period missing
person is often found national parks
national parks 600 people a lot of
people are currently missing yeah but
they they get found
some of them
and and oh some get found some of them
one thousand americans have vanished
without a trace probably eaten
see that's what people think but
you know how uncommon a [ __ ] bear
attack is dude it's i mean it's super
people in forest too
you know i went camping in yosemite once
and i'm not even joking so my friends
were
doing their thing getting stuff their
tents put up and everything i had to
take a dump there's no bathrooms because
it's like a really like foresty area so
i wanted to walk in
pretty far deep so no one sees me i took
a dump
and then i came i was like looking for a
campground i couldn't find it oh that's
terrifying i was freaking out i was like
and finally someone said
i could hear them and i went towards
that direction
i got lost just by trying to get down
that's what i'm [ __ ] with indonesian
rainforest that's even crazier yep i'm
in the old indonesian rainforest i went
go for a pp
and i got lost
and i was like i'm sure where i was
going was where i was going and i and my
sister just heard kathleen
adelaine and the diax who are the
indigenous people of that area they came
and found me in a couple seconds
chin will go back to that search because
i wanna know what park has the most
missing people i'm pretty sure it's
yellow or yeah yellowstone which
national park uh well it was on scroll
down it was down there it's a huge area
uh go to which national park is most
lake mead
where's like me dude that's like three
people because i'm making a year oh
really lake mead national workers wins
the top side with five or six dude
oh no i'm thinking like me period that's
like me how's it not more awareness dude
yeah where is this six hundred people
just finally missing in the [ __ ]
yeah
always drop breadcrumbs eight million
kids gone every year
ooh we're worried about kovid yeah
well
you know it might be aliens where where
is it where's that arizona it is it's
the same yeah it's the same way it's
it's worth the hoverboard five million
acres of mountains dude it's a lot
that's like kids i remember when i was
uh younger and uh a girl in my
neighborhood in mesa like not too far
from my crib uh got it uh abducted never
never found her name was
my biggest nightmare it was it was
insane like
like literally i think i don't even
think it was like fully nighttime i
think you know the sun was coming down a
little bit
and she was just out front on her
bicycle i think her sister might have
ran his side for like a second and then
next thing you know like the bike it was
just the bike outside yeah is is your
biggest nightmare insane dude it was
like it was like the scariest thing in
the neighborhood because it was just
like you can devise my kid's skin yeah
oh dude it was it was
yeah i think about yeah and they never
um they i don't yeah they never found
anything your parents are more than
anything i mean granted eight million
kids go missing anything i don't know
what was when we were kids how many kids
went missing in the 90s but now i feel
like people are more savvy to it yeah
hopefully parents are more aware of it
yeah this had to be 98 when that because
we have
yeah this is i mean it's just a sad
[ __ ] story
22 uh years ago she was you know 22 22
years ago yeah
but it's actually dropped yeah because
people became more aware in america for
sure yeah cause i like when i dropped my
son off at school you know for his first
day of kindergarten
you know i know his teach i met with his
teachers from the school i met the other
parents i was like my daddy's like man
you walked to school or you when you
were when you were five you walked two
miles
i don't think i could tell your
teacher's name i never met him i'm like
what when you were five yeah
he was like your brother
i have no idea like oh you just did your
thing
i was like man
i like what it takes i dropped her off i
know his teacher's name i text her i
know what where he's at at all times i
know the other kids in the class i know
they're i have their teachers their
parents numbers
it's nuts dude my dad was just like see
ya
yeah it was just different just
different time
different time it was more dangerous
back then
yeah cameras